bonjour à tous
[Musique]
il est bien une fois une jeune dame qui
aura 21 ans dans le grand livre des
records pour avoir des avants
exponentielle en
2015 ceci était un grand milliards une
feuille de 98 milliards et chaque jour
elle est carrément de la saint valentin
pour cette jeune femme pourquoi eh bien
chacun de ces amours là et c'est
le grand amour
il y met donc en parfaite sans en
quelques clics ou des démons sans doute
je le regarde et ge dont la forme est
d'affecter un peu trop beau pour être
vrai un véritable temps devait néanmoins
à l'instar de martin le quartier une
jeune femme que je connais très bien
nous faire
danser la 8 milliards à prendre la
planète étaient tous éco responsables
étaient unis dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique était tellement
influent de la planète qui faisaient
partie
avant leurs invités mais que devient un
rêve quand le fait que le ressasser bas
il reste gens nous dire que je n'ai fini
ton de prouver le contraire
mais je ne peux pas lui même et donc les
jaunards jalousie il faudra que
j'embrasse mon rêve pour le concret ne
serait ce qu'un outil et
elle réfléchit elle est vitale et puis
lui dira peut-être être acheminée à
montoir thibout de l'enfant est le maire
d'oullins
l'enfant est le père de l'homme ce genre
de rallye conservant nos sujets de
dissertation pour aider ce peuple
français
donc cette nation hellène et en amenant
la scène dans le monde du développement
tu vas elle en arrive à la conclusion
suivant pour avoir aidé un jeune est
soucieux de la [ __ ] de la planète
s'est très tôt qu'il faut éduquer au les
mouvements les germes de l'epo
responsable
c'est dans le contrat que valent elles
le programme mais un ultime ramaël qui
ira limoges faire sourire la planète
éléments
se fondant est dédié à des enfants de 6
à 15 ans et consiste en des ateliers
théoriques lors desquelles les termes
comme changement climatique pollution de
diversité en pointe écologique leur sens
expliqué dans mon langage terre à terre
qui leur est très accessible et surtout
de façon pratique
puisqu'il est important que ces enfants
s'épanouissent et développe des talents
des ateliers de poésie sont également
faits afin de leur permettre le dit
bédié les faire à mère nature
belle histoire imaginaire leur sont lui
est compté
afin de dévier leurs pensions sur
l'urgence de la question climatique
des athlètes de récitals sont également
faire afin qu'ils transforment d'être
déchets du quotidien en objet fortuite
il est donc on verra qui transformeront
des bouteilles plastiques en trousse ou
encore
à développer
ou encore des rouleaux de papier
toilette en porte stylo
puisque la question
de la pollution responsable de la
consommation durable est super
importante nous devrons côtés d'enfants
installeront également des jardins
potagers ils attendront donc à faire ami
ami avec la terre
ce qui est magnifique à la fin du
programme qu'ils élaborent ce que l'on
va appeler la charte geste éco geste et
qu'on peut dire gestes écologiques et
cette charte en fait c'est la version
green d'un dix commandements en effet
les enfants se réunissent font un
consensus et décide de digest qui
s'engagent à respecter au quotidien donc
on va retrouver sur cette chasse des
actions comme le palais dans la rue
éteindre la lumière quand on en a plus
besoin jeter ses ordures à la poubelle
en fait d'une action que tous autant que
nous sommes de briand à bach comme
habitude et cette chance est en réalité
les bausch sinon les fils de ce que moi
j'appelle le bas des licornes de
l'imparfait écolo un vade-mecum qui en
fait pour chaque lot source à préserver
reprendrait des actions qu'il faudrait
mener au quotidien
donc pour parler d'énergie comme mon
prédécesseur on pourra lire pour qu'on
va changer les ampoules énergivores en
ampoules moins consommatrices ou encore
virer carrément vers le solaire puisque
celui ci nous aident à combattre le
réchauffement climatique
pour en revenir à cette jeune dame
pendant qu'elle colle à coordonner et
collabore avec de jeunes dynamiques
d'ailleurs j'en aperçois ans dans la
salle sur le projet d'éducation
environnementale
elle a posé une seconde question
elle s'est demandée
comment faire pour que la flamme crime
reste entretenu chez les jeunes parce
qu'il faut bien se le dire en avant que
le père de l'homme ne devienne ans et
bien il ya une heure de transition vous
êtes bien d'accord avec moi voilà et
donc est servi
les jeunes cela qu'ils sont vraiment
épris des réseaux sociaux il serait
intéressant de les emmener voir toucher
du doigt ces choses là qu'on leur
demande de protéger à coude efforts
quotidiens
elle en a donc deux jeunes gens en
randonnée en forêt faire des ateliers de
développement durable dans cet
environnement naturel
découvrir des plantes en savourer les
fruits
pêcher du poisson se rendent compte que
celui ci est trop petit pour finir en
cuisine donc leur faire un petit 10 et
le ramener dans son environnement
naturel
cela pour quoi eh bien pourquoi ces
jeunes gens prennent conscience qu'il
peut aussi ne serait ce qu'avec une
photo comme celle là avec un message par
l'environnement
pension tease et leurs amis virtuels
pour dire que tous ensemble nous
pourrons lutter contre le changement
climatique et préserver notre
environnement
je suis sûr vous vous demandez pourquoi
les jeunes et les enfants sont au centre
des actions que mène cette jeune homme
et bien la réponse est toute simple les
jeunes et les enfants représentent une
forte proportion de la population
mondiale et ces jeunes sont en réalité
les prochains green preneur pour dire
entrepreneurs vers ce genre
d'entrepreneurs là qui apporte des
solutions écologiques à des problèmes
sociaux et ce genre d'entrepreneurs que
cette jeune dame a également décidé de
mettre la lumière sur eux afin que
beaucoup d'autres personnes le découvre
et donc sept jeunes gens sont les
prochains feliz tabac initiateur de la
force et kodjo qui consiste à courir
tout en ramassant des déchets plastiques
afin que ceux-ci la chef d'alors course
dans nos océans qui sont déjà pollué par
5 milliards de morceaux de plastique
selon une étude de national geographic
ces jeunes gens sont également les
prochaines crises at you concepteur de
la poubelle connectés green for médium
qui est un résultat de la transformation
de réfrigérateurs usagers
ces jeux sont également les prochains à
soldado qui m l'inventivité j'en ai une
au service de la planète ils sont pour
finir les prochains et d'almeida qui ont
compris ce nom qui a compris que le mot
ordures ne raisonne pas comme le monde a
du coup rien juge et qu'en réalité
les ordures
mérite un véritable travail d'enfer
volée qui passe de la collecte à la
valorisation en passant table de
traitement d'eau pour finir par valoir
leur pesant d'or sur le marché
international
ces jeunes gens sont ce que je j'appelle
en fait des businessman qui vont prouver
aux gens que préserver la planète n'est
pas que synonyme de privations en fait
tout dépend de l'angle où on décide de
se positionner le commander c'est de
voir les choses
si vous vous demandez en fait quelle est
cette jeune dame dont je ne cesse de
parler de plus long terme de mon propos
je vous dirais qu'elle est celle là qui
aujourd'hui
arborent la couleur qui qualifie le
mieux notre planète elle est celle là
qui n'a de cesse de dire qu'un milliard
d'un parfait écolo c'est bien mieux que
ce même nombre se tournant les pouces
elle est celle là qui tout à l'heure bah
passer la main à un autre speaker cette
jeune larmor y compris ses droits
j'espère donc avec ses applaudissements
chacun d'entre vous ressortira de cette
salle avec une fibre écolo naissance ou
confiant mais avec des résolutions qui
doit s'engager à respecter pas comme
celle comprend début d'année des
résolutions qui vont consister en un
geste écologique à faire au quotidien
pourquoi parce que je suis convaincu que
la cré contre les changements
climatiques
résident en et surtout dans le
changement de nos habitudes quotidiennes
en réalité nous sommes tous sur un même
bateau un bateau de croisière
dont nous profitons des bienfaits depuis
des milliers sinon des centaines ou tout
ce que vous voulez d'années et se bat on
en a oublié de faire de la maintenance
notre chance aujourd'hui c'est que nous
savons qu'un déluge est imminent et nous
avons nous pouvons changer les choses
nous pouvons commencer par curé ce
bateau changer quelques pièces
défectueuses en suivant les différentes
actions qui ont été proposées qui seront
proposés en quoi après - et puis en fait
augmenter la résilience de notre bateau
entre ne rien faire pour finir tous
naufragés et perd chacun
naufragés et faire chacun un effort
quotidien pour lutter contre le
changement climatique
je pense que le choix est clair je vous
remercie